identify the hypothesis in conclusion of
the following statement and determine
whether the statement is always
sometimes or never true so let's see
what the statement is we have X well
this should be an x squared plus 5x plus
7 is greater than zero for all real
numbers X so first let's rewrite this as
a bit of a proposition as an if-then
statement and it becomes a lot easier to
identify the hypothesis and the
conclusion so we could rewrite this as
if X is a real number real number then
this is true then x squared plus 5x plus
7 is greater than 0 and when you write
it as an if-then statement like this it
becomes a lot easier to identify the
hypothesis and there couldn't come the
conclusion now the hypothesis is
generally just what the if part is is
conjuring up so this right here in pink
X is a real number that's the hypothesis
sometimes it's called the antecedent
that is the hypothesis hypothesis and as
we said in previous videos it's
different although related to the notion
of a scientific hypothesis here we're
dealing with the hypothesis of a
hypothetical proposition don't want to
confuse you too much it's the it's what
is it's what's inside of the if part of
the statement the conclusion is the
conclusion from the Danner it's the
consequent right here then that that
right there is a conclusion conclusion
we could have labeled this to the
conclusion here is this statement right
here that right there is the conclusion
that is what you conclude if X is a real
number so you could say for all that is
the hypothesis right therefore all real
numbers X that is the hypothesis either
way you want to do it it's always easier
to write it as an if-then statement now
the more interesting question is whether
this statement is always sometimes or
never true and the first thing that
might pop out at you is that the
coefficient on the highest degree term
here on the x squared term it's a
positive coefficient
so this is going to be an upward-opening
parabola it's going to be an
upward-opening parabola let me draw that
so this is the x-axis if this is the
x-axis right there whether this is
always sometimes or never true rests on
whether the vertex whether the minimum
point of this parabola is above or below
the x-axis let me draw it for you so if
the parabola looks like this then for
any X you pick for any X you pick the
value of the function the value of x
squared plus 5x plus 7 is always going
to be greater than zero if the function
looks like this if the function looks
like this then you're going to have some
values for X where it score greater than
zero but you're going to have some
values for X where it is equal or less
than zero so we have to we have to
determine whether it's it's above or
maybe I guess on or below the x-axis and
that's the y-value of the vertex now we
know that it's not never true we know
that it's not never true because this is
an upward-opening parabola even if your
vertex is a negative number eventually
if you get far enough away from it
you're going to get positive values of
this function so we know it's not never
true we just have to decide between
always and sometimes and to figure that
out let's figure out where the vertex
and in particular where the y-value of
the vertex is but in order to get that
y-value need the x value so the x-value
of the vertex X of the vertex there's a
formula here I normally don't like
giving formulas but we've shown this in
multiple videos before it's negative B
over 2a and I can't help myself if you
look at the quadratic formula it comes
straight out of that no cryotic formula
is negative B over well I'll write it as
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac all of that over
2a or you can write it as negative B
over 2a plus or minus this thing over 2a
you normally just see it with a big 2a
in the denominator but you could split
it up like this and notice this right
here is a formula I just told you as a
formula for the x-value of the vertex
which makes complete sense because the
vertex is always going to be along the
line of symmetry of our parabola and it
is going to be equal distant it's going
to be equal distant from each of
each of the zeros so you get a zero in
the plus direction this is the distance
right here this is one of the zeros in
the plus direction and then if you
subtract that's the other zero so it
makes sense that negative B over 2a
is the x-value of the line of symmetry
or the x-value of the vertex now that
said let's actually figure out what the
x-value of the vertex is for this
problem so we have X square
sor-sorry so negative B over 2a so this
is equal to negative 5 because b is 5
over 2 times 1 over 2 so that's the
x-value let's figure out where it sits
whether it's whether the y-value for the
vertex is below or above the x-axis so
the y-value just will just have to
substitute into this the y-value of the
vertex is going to be equal to negative
5 halves squared negative 5 halves
squared plus 5 times negative 5 halves
and then finally plus 7 let's see if
this is positive or not so negative 5
halves squared is 25 over 4 minus 25
over 2 minus 25 over 2 plus 7 and so we
can add these let's put everything over
4 so this is equal to 25 over 4 25 over
2 is the same thing as 50 over 4 minus
50 over 4 plus 28 over 4 plus 28 over 4
and this is equal to well we know our
denominator is going to be 4 and you
have 25 plus 28 is 53 minus 50 is 3 so
it equals positive 3 fourths so the
y-value is it is positive it is above
the x-axis so the parabola will look
something like this the problem would
look something like this where the
y-value is 3/4 for the vertex the
x-value we just saw is negative 5 halves
and because the minimum point of this
upward-opening parabola is a positive
number the minimum y-value is a positive
number it's always going to have values
at that level or above it so it this is
true for all real if X is a real number
then it is true it is always true it is
always true that x squared plus 5x plus
7 is greater than
zero